Freunde ich frage mich auch wie das
immer funktioniert von jetzt auf gleich
tauchen einfach die Weihnachtsmärkte auf
und es dauert nicht lange bis man auch
in Weihnachtsstimmung ist und heute sind
wir vor einem Weihnachtsmarkt hier in
Köln und wir werden einfach mal eine
Runde darüber drehen und werden alles
essen worauf wir Lust haben das klingt
doch nach einem Plan ich hoffe ihr habt
genauso viel Lust darauf wie ich legen
wir los
[Musik]
wir starten mit einem absoluten
Klassiker Reibekuchen also wirklich
jedes Jahr wenn ich auf dem
Weihnachtsmarkt gehe das allererste was
ich mir hole und heute auch ganz
klassisch mit Apfelmus es gibt natürlich
noch die Varianten mit Lachs mit Creme
fraiche und so Zwiebeln und so auch
alles super aber das hier ist so der
perfekte Kontrast so kenne viele Leute
die auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt irgendwie
mal süß mal salzig Essen hier ist
einfach beides deshalb einmal rein das
Apfelmus
es gibt wenige Orte die so sehr für
komfortfood stehen wie ein
Weihnachtsmarkt alles ist einfach nur
darauf ausgelegt euch glücklich zu
machen egal wie viel Öl dran ist beim
Frittieren egal wie viel Zucker drin ist
das ist einfach die Zeit ist Jahres wo
man sich einfach gut gehen lässt und bei
so einem Reibekuchen kann es einem nur
gut geben ich freue mich auf all das was
wir heute noch essen werden aber das
hier die sind so knusprig so perfekt
frittiert ist schon eine echte Ansage
schreibt mir gerne mal euren
Weihnachtsmarkt Klassiker was für euch
die Nummer eins auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt
ist in die Kommentare wirklich das ist
so perfekt weil es ist so knusprig die
Chips schon fast aber innen drin
trotzdem noch so schön weich
und so danach ist man nicht so satt
checkst du so die isst man so aber wie
bei Chips kann man einfach so immer
weiter essen das absolut recht danach
kann man noch einige einige andere
Sachen essen und genau das machen wir
suchen wir es war die nächste Speise
heraus und ich lasse mir noch gut gehen
[Musik]
hier haben wir jetzt flammlachs habe ich
noch nie gegessen Eric meinte das gibt's
aber überall ich fand es aber so
interessant dass mir sowieso geholt
hätte die haben jetzt eine extra große
Portion 14 €, das kostet schon teuer
deshalb sollte es besser etwas können
wir hier mal so eine Gabel der ist vor
dem Holz Feuer gegart ich habe das ja
gerade selbst gesehen das sieht schon
wirklich toll aus und normalerweise
kriegt er den Brötchen oder so wir haben
jetzt einfach nur genommen und ich
probiere mal
der ist krass ja das ist so dieser
Holzkohle Geschmack ist crazy der zieht
durch den ganzen Lachs der Lachs selbst
trotzdem aber innen drin noch echt
glasig und so sehr sehr saftig war
wirklich köstlich also ich glaube
kleinere Weihnachtsmärkte so ein Dorf
und so kennen das vielleicht auch nicht
also ich habe gesagt zum ersten Mal hier
gesehen das ist schon super Sache total
leicht aber trotzdem sind kräftiger
geräucherter Geschmack sehr sehr gut ist
eine Sache die ich auf jeden Fall auch
häufiger geworden Weihnachtsmarkt essen
werde saftig Bruder heute ein bisschen
wie schaffe ich das so viel zu essen
Ausprobieren
der Salat kann Weg für mich aber der
Luxus ist sehr sehr lecker das waren 200
Gramm und 300 Gramm kosten im Laden 8 9
€ und das ist okay aber ist es auch sehr
qualitativ hochwertig und frisch gemacht
und über Feuer und alles was wir schon
gesagt haben
[Musik]
als nächstes haben wir Chips die kennt
man wahrscheinlich eher so im
Grenzgebiet wir sind ja nicht allzu weit
weg von den Niederlanden und da kennt
man natürlich diese
miniaturpfannkuchen extra ein spezieller
Grill oder wie auch immer man diese
Vorrichtung nennen möchte so wie ich die
kenne sind die innen drin super fluffig
dazu Nutella und Puderzucker und mehr
kann man eigentlich gar nicht machen ich
liebe das willst du das für mich
Weihnachtsmarkt nicht so von süß zu
salzig Angeln und so das ist schon echt
was besonderes und ich probiere jetzt
mal
so richtig dicken Nutella drauf so der
klebt so der Mund beim Essen der
Puderzucker ist so die Kirsche auf der
Sahnetorte was ich am Anfang gesagt habe
mit Komfort food das stimmt einfach zu
100%. wir sollten es nicht bereuen wir
sollten es einfach genießen genauso
weitermachen
[Musik]
das hier ist Langosch eine ungarische
Spezialität Hefeteig frittiert in einem
Bad aus Fett bis er golden braun ist
obendrauf Speck Creme fraiche
Knoblauchöl Käse komfortfood ist wieder
mal das Stichwort und das ist glaube ich
für mich der Preis leistungssieger des
heutigen Tages egal was noch kommt weil
das ist so ein aparillo und der kostet 6
€ findet man auf dem ein oder anderen
Weihnachtsmarkt und ich habe es letztes
Jahr für mich entdeckt glaube dann fünf
Mal oder so hier auf dem gleichen
Weihnachtsmarkt sogar gegessen mag ich
richtig gerne und wir lassen uns einfach
mal schmecken
mir fehlen gerade die Worte ist perfekt
zu beschreiben
also das schmeckt einfach auch so so
fettig und so unfassbar gut und davon
wird er auch wirklich satt also so
unfair dass das schmeckt wirklich sehr
gut aber das Ding ist vielleicht ist das
gar nicht strategisch so klug weil das
ist und dann bist du satt dann kannst du
halt bei vielen verschiedenen Spots noch
essen dafür kriegst du wirklich halt
echt viel für dein Geld auch dieses
Knoblauchöl aber probiert du das erstmal
super lecker versuche so eine Ecke zu
bekommen wo ich auch direkt schon Speck
und alles habe
aber das müssen wir jetzt echt zu viert
essen weil sonst werden wir sterben wir
hauen das weg also suchen uns was Süßes
[Musik]
das durfte einfach nicht fehlen was soll
ich Euch erzählen das ist halt ein
Crêpes mit Nutella aber gleichermaßen
ist es für mich der Weihnachtsmarkt
Klassiker das ist wirklich immer die
eine Sache die ich mir unbedingt holen
musste vor allem früher aber auch jetzt
man sieht schon so dadurch so wie freie
gefühlt der ist mit Nutella lass uns
einfach essen und genießen den Leuten
wird so schlecht angucken wegen dem
Karussell
wirklich ungeschlagen für mich so dieser
weiche Teig so diese Masse genau
Weihnachtsmarkt aufgefallen
so viel maximum eine Sache schaffe ich
danach noch dann gehe ich sowas von
schlafen und dann war ich wahrscheinlich
auch erst nächstes Jahr zu Weihnachten
wieder auf aber das hier ist ein Muss
zehn von zehn es ist einfach geil
verdrückt das jetzt dann rolle ich zum
nächsten stand dort sehen wir uns dann
bin gespannt was es sein wird
[Musik]
also Leute hier habe ich was Feines ein
Weihnachtsklassiker der natürlich auch
nicht fehlen darf wir haben hier Maronen
ich muss ehrlich gestehen das habe ich
noch gar nicht allzu oft gegessen also
ich habe mir auch gerade gedacht so in
jedem Weihnachtslied und so wird immer
über Maronen gesungen deshalb muss ich
sie jetzt mal probieren eigentlich sehr
unspektakulär ich glaube viele denken
gerade was labert ja aber ich habe
wirklich noch nie mehr auf dem
Weihnachtsmarkt warum geholt und ich
dachte mir das vielleicht was Gutes so
zum Abschluss weil es nicht ganz so
krass ist nicht so fertig nicht so zu
kriegen sondern einfach traditionell
ein bisschen süßer als gedacht mehlig
wenn man kauft wird das auch so cremig
irgendwie wahrscheinlich nicht das
leckerste was wir heute hatten aber
dafür das Tradition Ihr wie ich auch
sind heute auf unsere Kosten gekommen
wir haben fast alles gegessen was ist
hier auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt gab und
spätestens nach diesem Video bin ich
jetzt in Weihnachten Stimme ihr
vielleicht auch ich brauche es aber eine
kleine Pause von Weihnachten bis zum
nächsten Mal ciao